with headlines like these you're
probably where I am at home for a Travel
columnist being stuck inside is not
ideal but I'm learning that it does have
its perks the coffee is closed no need
for headphones and the travel deals are
big in August you could fly New York to
San Francisco for 255 dollars and that's
round-trip blesse Angeles to Chicago 104
dollars and you get to come back
Washington DC to New Orleans 133 dollars
before you get excited now is not the
time to be dumb and dangerous you
shouldn't travel during a pandemic
just because fares are cheap but the
bargains extend beyond the forecast
sheltering periods so the question is
should you buy well it depends on what
you're booking
let's start with flights according to
booking app hopper domestic air fares
for summer and fall trips were down 36%
compared to the same period last year
some like this $41 Boston to Orlando
roundtrip in June we're even better than
that and while it's hard to know what
will be happening in June the cheapness
of domestic flights make them worth the
gamble airlines are currently selling
these tickets without cancellation or
change fees meaning if you do end up
unable to travel you'll get a voucher
for a later trip the trip may not work
out for you if the crisis extends but
you won't have much money tied up in the
ticket and you can't apply it to later
trips if you do get to go on that $41
fare you win the risk isn't worth it for
international travel at least not this
year
sure seeing a $280 round-trip from New
York to Paris is tempting but
international travel restrictions may
remain in place for some time and even
if they're lifted consider how far from
home you want to be as there could be
yet more local outbreaks of the corona
virus so wait on your international
trips and be flexible when you do booked
airlines are dropping lots of roots and
those schedule changes
may force you to travel earlier or later
than expected as for cruises this one is
simpler you should wait coronavirus shut
down the three big operators for at
least 30 days possibly longer even after
they're back on the water I expect there
will be a long term concern about cruise
ships and the possible recurrence of
viral outbreaks ultimately will depend
on your personal comfort level the news
of the diamond princess and the grand
princess dominated headlines and showed
how a viral outbreak can spread in a
confined space if you're looking for a
hotel however now might be the time to
book as long as it's refundable
occupancy rates are way down marriott
says it has lost 90% of its bookings for
example that means hotels are dropping
prices to fill rooms even luxury hotels
which try to avoid discounts are
offering fourth and fifth night free
deals and waiving prepayment and
cancellation penalties according to
travel sellers no matter what don't book
anything with cancellation fees we just
don't know how long the coronavirus is
going to keep us homebound on that point
it's just fine to wait travel experts
say when this is over there will be huge
sales to get people traveling again
you